robert werner s'est rendu à la planque
comme l'on dit de mesrine rue belliard à
y rencontrer ceux qui depuis quelques
jours ont croisé dans l'escalier jacques
mesrine
sans le reconnaître bien sûr
derrière cette fenêtre celle de
l'appartement de mesrine des policiers
perquisitionnent il est 20 heures
ces prises de vues a été fait dans la
cour de l'immeuble
et voici la façade donnant sur la rue
mesrine se faisait appeler tout vol tous
les demeures et rue belliard à quelques
pas de la porte de clignancourt ou
internet
et c'était un voisin comme les autres
locataires comme les autres il habita
qu'elle était troisième avec une madame
tout seul quelles étaient ses allers
venues régulière le matin le soir non
hemera numéraire apparemment oui
et quand il venait y restait pas
longtemps dans l'appartement s'en sortir
enfin vous sortir vraiment venus en deux
fois par semaine si vous voulez puis je
vais rentrer et de faire ressortir son
courrier jamais de courir mais je jouais
avec la barre d'abord oui c'est l'avion
que je n'ai qui change tout vous aviez
lui qui l'avait ruiné mais paul tools ne
figure pas sur ce panneau pourtant le
nom de tous les locataires les voisins
on ignorait tout de ce monsieur qui ne
faisait pas de bruit ne parlaient à
personne ils le croiser dans l'escalier
parfois le matin en venant de refermer
leur journal relatant la terre mesrine
précisément vous avez prises alors
qu'ils avaient appris que s'ils
habitaient dans la même maison
la rue belliard donne sur le métro
clignancourt dans l'appartement de
mesrine on s'est trouvé en présence d'un
dispositif anti policiers portent
matelassé pour les balles entre autres
mais ce soir on commande toujours les
faits et ce à quoi un petit peu partout
il y avait des
les inspecteurs en civil qui avait des
mitraillettes parallèlement les
pistolets sa cavale et ouais c'est un
petit peu la pole man général et voient
ce que j'ai vu j'ai vu un monsieur qui
était au volant il avait
le sang partout de la tête remet
cette année sinon je viens pas du tout
il y avait une femme qui est à côté de
lui qui est sorti de la voiture et qui
est tombé par terre à partir de ce manga
est arrêté il était blessé
après
moi je n'ai vu blessé ici sur le côté là
il certainement la tête parce que ça
c'est pas mal
et puis après la preuve en a pas il ya
des traces de faillite qui aurait vu
tous les bains douches et les ovnis et
là elle s'est échappée il est allé au
total est sorti de la voiture il avait
sorti elle est tombée par terre débat
nuit l'autre côté nom était pas évaluer
parce qu'ils l'ont relevé et l'on
assiste à une borne ici était consciente
des prix évaluée et je crois qu'après ce
heiva nui
[Musique]